direction la tunisie où la situation
épidémique est catastrophique
le ministre de la santé était limogée la
campagne de vaccination est chaotique
le tout alors que le pays célèbre l'aïd
al kébir une des plus importantes fêtes
musulmanes mais cette année les
tunisiens n'ont pas le coeur à la fête
ce alors que beaucoup ont des proches en
réanimation d'autres faute de moyens ont
dû faire l'impasse sur la célébration de
cette fête les précisions de notre
correspondant à tunis à celle xavi la
fête du sacrifice sur la cérémonie la
plus importante du calendrier musulman à
cette année un goût amer en cause d'une
crise économique sans précédent et une
situation sanitaire des plus
inquiétantes face au manque de moyens
beaucoup de tunisiens ont dû faire
l'impasse sur cette célébration écoutez
je n'ai pas fêté l'aïd cette année ni
moi ni mes frères car nous n'avons pas
les moyens
notre peuple est pauvre et on est devenu
encore plus pauvres depuis ce qu'ils
appellent la révolution j'ai une
maîtrise en droit privé et je n'ai rien
célébré cette année
comment voulez vous que je pense à
acheter un mouton alors qu'il n'est même
pas les moyens d'acheter un poulet cette
année je n'ai pas fêté l'aïd et je ne
suis pas la seule dans ce cas
ma famille mes amis et même les voisins
tout simplement car la vie est devenue
trop chère dites-moi qui peut se payer
un mouton à 700 800 voire mille dinars
alors que je ne gagne que 300 dinars par
mois
si j'enlève mes factures d'électricité
d'eau et les frais d'éducation de ma
fille il ne me reste rien je suis veuve
comment voulez vous que je m'en sorte
comment voulez vous que j'aille au
marché pour acheter les courses et des
fêtes
il n'y aucune organisation cette année
pour les fêtes au niveau du gouvernement
les différents ministères ne sont même
pas capables de se mettre d'accord sur
un protocole sanitaire pour permettre la
célébration de l'aïd
les tunisiens ont leurs habitudes leurs
traditions mais cette année avec la
crise du coc vide rien ne peut se passer
comme d'habitude le monde entier souffre
du coc vide mais en tunisie c'est pire
qu'ailleurs car les caisses de l'état
sont à sec crise politique économique
encore sanitaires ont balayé
l'effervescence habituelle qui règne en
cette période de fêtes alors que le
gouvernement a promis une sortie de
crise politique et une accélération de
la campagne de vaccination pour freiner
la recrudescence des cas de
contamination au coville 19 alors que la
communauté internationale s'est montrée
solidaire
le pays dispose désormais d'environ 3,2
millions de doses et devrait passer à 5
millions de vaccins disponibles vers la
mi août
peut être un bon début pour que la
tunisie sortent enfin de son cauchemar